jean-pierre tel vin ge est l'auteur de
plusieurs ouvrages en langue provençale
tu as écrit quelques livres dans le
dialecte rhodanien jonah est criante
dans le dialecte maritime la vieille
hockey awards la vieille quéro morte
voilà alors je vais te dire moi j'ai un
complexe comptant que provençal c'est de
savoir que notre grande langue est
divisé en autant de dialectes alors est
ce normal
les grecs anciens parler par dialecte
n'était pas complexés le phénomène
dialectal c'est le phénomène normal qui
accompagne toute toute langue vivante
tout grande toucan d'ensemble de langues
vivantes pendant des millénaires les
langues se sont transmises ainsi par
tradition orale et elle était
différencier d'une petite localité à une
autre et maintenant encore partout il
n'y a pas ou la grande langue nationale
n'a pas fait disparaître complètement
les dialectes et bien même dans la
france du nord
on parle encore par dialecte c'est une
richesse c'est oui c'est une richesse
bien sûr voilà alors en provence tu as
également de grandes familles de
dialectes qui sont elles-mêmes séparés
ont toutes petites divisions dialectal
qui permettait autrefois et même encore
maintenant de reconnaître quelqu'un à la
manière dont il s'exprime on ira
toujours maintenant t as qu est-ce qu il
ait de mirandol parce que à mérindol on
ne prononce pas le r voilà alors je
pense qu'il serait intéressant de savoir
grosso modo quelles sont les limites
dans lesquelles sont parlés ces
différents dialectes en provence est
d'abord quelles sont ces quatre grands
dialecte et bien les cases et quatre
grandes familles dialectal c'est d'abord
le maritime le maritime celui qui a le
plus de locuteurs qui est parlée grosso
modo de martigues jusqu à antibes avec
comme limite nord à peu près la durance
et le var et puis tu as à l'ouest le
rhodanien qui ai parlé de part et
d'autre du rhône
le centre du rhodanien c'est avignon ça
déborde jusque à uzès nîmes en
particulier sur l'autre rive
tu as le nid soeur qui lui n'a pas subi
tellement l'influencent du français et
puis tu as dans le reste de la provence
les dialectes gaveau c'est à dire les
dialectes alpin qui eux sont assez
différencier bon et bien coûteux si tu
veux nous avons tout de suite voir quel
est le premier dialectes parlés en
provence c'est à dire le dialecte
rhodanien avec la voix de marcel bonet
entre cloud by les louviérois comme
pringuet qu'elle a hobo savant savent
faguet signale un pic en design et les
flamands sabouret route outils lavaur ou
d'autres mutants résistants basse
perrine traouc en de moore nice la news
et robin passade une corde et le nahd et
minka kelly déclaré tiago monteiro falga
ou bernard au style dépatouiller mme
plante à la teste du live et des bars
beauvaisiens sous-tend des cookies it
qui met la lune les agatha y rêver des
millions et qui perd ses gardes est
brave et la tourner virouil anneaux
passade escalé et pringuet sa vie à la
cause du mas de pierre quand c'est des
vies naissent humour nice mêmes balles
en dalles à l'entrée les douze jours
nissen d'avaler my populaire radicova
d'où les premiers rangs de tout cas
bonne terre que d'un tout nouveau
party-game creed est ce pas vous demand
et au lit ni 0 à bozouls un malade et
sorgues et une gastal ionisé scratch es1
et bailey ou loumaye aînée relève anne
que ça veut dire juste dc10 la
blanquette zakho qui brigue ou de crever
ou les pyromanes qu'à vous et découvrez
alors en maïs aux braves comme pas ou
des sentiers personne voyait sa trace
eco qui paie cieux des plus moroses que
louvain tous les daou bakaba a modélisé
cependant dit int belgique de cacao
compagne et bondy mois atteint 9,1 et
quelles sont les caractéristiques de ce
dialecte aux rhodaniens bien le
rhodanien s'est le plus évolué
directeur provençaux c'est à dire celui
qui a subi diront les spécialistes la
plus grande mesure phonétique à
l'oreille celui qui est le plus doux on
peut entendre par exemple le jour
c'est presque le jour il ya des endroits
où c'est complètement l'autre jour
pitcho bixio pitso lagnieu lizio
l'annuaire les ou à marseille tu vois
une corps une qu à marseille
et puis alors des mots qui diffère par
exemple le pit show qui sera picchu qui
sera plutôt picchu marseille
voilà voilà quelles sont les
caractéristiques voyais avec rhodanien
bon ben maintenant nous allons voir un
petit peu le dialecte niçois avec l'abbé
loi de francis gag dans un texte d
ailleurs qu'il a été lui-même
monseigneur reçu l'été miracle et non
sivas il obtint donc prometteuse line
faire pire ump katsoulis tu savais
zealand obtiendrait 20 des mercedes et
une acuité poc
notre avis qui trop raso mis en oeuvre
des crottes michael hommes de glen rice
avait l'esprit qu'un durant l'hiver tant
que nos vies nous verrez pas au liberia
dans quel s au contenu de deux heures
dans le soirée lat l'esprit tabac isat
sens à audrey souci que le salut de
l'anima mieux si mohamed gueye ma cour
avec la prime cours et le premier gré ou
encre épatera brusque de la vigne courra
le broussy clair vous effrayons pour
appareils sous les pins dont d'azpi tout
éteindre
serhat une contrée de l' autre grief
fait à marc coma passeront déni de cire
et par an de frais courants à la fleur
de lys qui s'esclaffent à la terre est
ma dur alors un gremlin corvée ouariba
l'avion cote après un cadastre bracket
et coulis andry gros muscles
mousquetaires negra ou epa série en
cours highco 4-2 dans la biotine clope
et fume on l'a testé me gonfle au piège
hakim aux seniors chinois mais des
crottes et notions plus qu'un show culte
travers pam indiqué francis gag
bon alors les caractéristiques des
lumières et la sarre c'était un parler
qui est moins évoluées comme le
languedocien il nous donne un peu une
idée de ce que pouvait être le provençal
au moyen-âge les consonnes finales comme
prononce p4 soul est la féminine le
féminin à époque assouka rusca encore
une consonne finales que j'ai relevé
piech
c'est une situation très curieuse ce qui
rend ce qui ressemble assez peu récit
provençal ce qui empêche pas de nous
comprenons très bien c'est qu'elle
déborde jusqu'au piémont
voilà les bords du sco piémont bon il ya
maintenant nous allons voir justement le
parler gaveau avec la voix de magnan de
forcalquier et nous allons comparer
sencha r&d dre thierry lupi joke amine
déferré akwa ibom par les grandes lignes
ont été sa fan jam prayssas et moon
telle ou les olé au couteau my part à
kelly fois que la grande anse au dos
viaggi c'est ce qui intrigue coloré
valou et miesque d'affronter l'obstacle
l'autre et viraux à colin batch opa
daguet mountada et d'aval aux paumes
tournées route aux passantes fin
kheloufi doctrine guélou parcours
bousquet tout un puma tchad et fument
blanc négret bouffer déjà et menace
autant la moutade vitesse est déjà un
rêve qui est sûre espen musée regia
d'une esplanade mandat d'inler louvier
souci blâmer news et préau les tnt
fajr est posée tôt 18 no picciotto
garraud floride
alors après le dialecte des harpes
direct gaveau quels sont les remarques
que tu nous fais là dessus eh bien je
dirais qu'il pourrait y avoir une gaveau
plus caractéristique celui ci ressemble
pas mal aux maritimes
on aurait pu être par exemple trouver le
gaveau dans lequel on prenant ce que la
cabre la charmante bon mais on peut
relever la cour pour la colline il
serait quoi là à marseille
quoi alors dans le var collomb en
rhodanien
sur le stand pour sur les nintendo dans
maritime suivi peine devant rhodanien
voilà alors pour parler du maritime
venant en fête à ton pays puisque je
suis un écrivain de langue maritime
dernièrement son livre maritime venant
un petit peu sur le parler de zones de
marseille avec bernard rémusat m de long
10 km ont été soit mal bastings par les
monnaies mais il travailla d'où les
quartiers les deux barques à l épisode
où les portes a failli à l'aller à la
cool thing
démonter seulement les pilotes
reviennent dans la commune qu'ils
acquittent karim olly barkley escanaux à
la paie son loyer vie va où
si charles allen ausy l'écart à 10 à feu
ce cadre les bras et pays souligne el
nina keil howling marseillaise grande
adresse aux picards river et met les
points sur i jeunes que messi gros
cotillons pika et c'est quoi il faut
canada kelly va t'amener est à meyer
kaelin d'accueil quartier saint john
créé la politique pescado et suta et de
musc et mais signale des femmes et des
enfants qui courent sur rendez vous mme
faye richir botola base de la canebière
omar kadhr de sparte amélie veille et
henri ben ali car est des bastides en
quarts garde pour mandataire de migros
et d'êtres humains dédiés aux mirabelles
haut du tableau de blank qu il fallait
car outre les verrines ou dans la maille
porter liz péricard la citière des
ballasts cela test complet des migrants
et de 6 sur les espagnols qui viennent
nous les gars voulaient tablant que les
dilemmes brugada bitonto où guy bono
n'aime pas sarko qui m'offre de tout
logo de martigues mondiale indochine
questions est une femme housses et
coques et violée a cofondé bts evento
cas aussi pour une part mba da au marché
des glaciers situé sur le port aucune
pudeur carrière le dieu de dubaï
aucun groupe ares et le pasteur de
quatre sous persil et voilà c'est c'est
une belle page du journal à certains que
nous
rusal la sarthe dis moi tes remarques
sur le dialecte maritime le dialecte
maritime je dirais plutôt ici le direct
marcy et qui est une des formes du
maritime il et il a quelque chose de
plus sauvage de rudes des remarques et
des façon inimitable de prononcer le r
la canebière et puis il a ses formes
particulières par exemple
l'idiot pour je lui dis tout bendouiou
la façon de prononcer le yoo final dont
on pourrait faire des centaines de
remarques sur le marseillais voilà alors
en conclusion nous avons vu des quatre
collectes
peut-on dire carrément qu'il y ait une
compréhension facile entre les
différentes tenant des dialectes bien
entendu surtout pour les gens qui ont
appris leur landau berceau pour ceux qui
l'ont apprise dans le livre il faut un
certain temps d'exercice marc face à
harry très facile enfin peut-on imaginer
qu'on tourne un film par exemple un
dialecte aux rhodaniens et le projeter
dans une salle marseillaise et qu'ils
soient contient l'entendît pas problème
est inverse serait serait vrai également
diverses bon eh bien nous avons terminé
sur ce cette langue marseillais cette
langue maritime que tu en aurais avec
ton vivre si tu veux qu'on la belle
feinte devant demander à un chanteur
marseillais en ricaner taux de nous
évoquer la grande blague de victor gélu
très bien et bien puisqu'il faut que je
fasse j'ai lu je vais faire comme j'ai
lu il arrivait il enlever sa veste
il enlevait sa cravate il déboutonner
son col et ils retrousser ses manches et
ensuite teignant l'ex-romain hui qu 1,2
par la politique menée par interdire
haine mais pas celle-là et publique
l'eau à waziers d'audard dieu
c'est mme patry ma aviez tout la bribe
one by one free cobra les rangs derrière
venus fouiller au perthus et les rimes
arias dédié et qu'elle avait pu blique
de reste géré le premier désir audience
caire par sonia despars dromas groupe
dédié l'opérer qu'un grand défi
le pays